[Music]
how many of you guys one of the actors
in this room I kind of do I already am
yes how about you yeah would you want to
be an actor sure yeah
what if I said that you have new
competition to compete with for
auditions now who like a [ __ ] AE
iRobot like tic toc oh I don't think I
could play that role this person I think
I show you robot baby pretty yeah she's
already booked her first role what I
[ __ ] a beater through the audition
process her legs [ __ ] no up yeah I'll
be way more talented than she is
I think Joe is gonna be pretty butch
isn't Bruce so there's evidence but she
might be my ass cuz she doesn't get hurt
I know she might be hella strong I know
it'll feel pain or rejection they're
made for acting they'll keep going
through auditions and they'll be like
thank you I tried my little robotic on
that if you show me that picture in
Denton was Rove I wouldn't have thought
you were to jerk off to it initially I
wouldn't have thought so he wants to
believe he wants to be from far away
yeah maybe from that angle
the minute you turn that around and look
like a fake person for this Inglis from
over here look like a girl in Harajuku
yeah true well here's another angle
agree does this look like a fake person
yes she looks like she used the the fact
that she has like people here that looks
like they're [ __ ] programmer yeah you
could tell there's real people this is
very Japanese she does well this she is
made by a Japanese AI company and the
reason why she got the role is that one
she's actually made for the role they
actually designed her to be the actress
in a movie but because of the whole
coronavirus and a lockdown all them film
industry is looking for ways to be safer
when it comes to you know
like intimate scenes and just you know
having less people on set like there's a
whole thing about like not having extras
anymore and like eating green screen
like green screen and just you know
placing things digitally afterwards and
not needing to have a whole bunch of
like you know having a hundred people in
the background where editors I know so
another way to curb the whole
coronavirus thing for the film industry
is to maybe you start looking into
technology to have robot actors now how
about the tech direction though that I
got I need more like emotion I don't I'm
not programmed for this you just got to
go to the back and program the director
it's a little ironic that most movies
made about robots are about how bad of
an idea they are why don't we get them
in the let's go all it is this gonna be
like a love romance movie do you know
what kind of story so the movie I think
has it there's no real title of [ __ ]
robot the movies called be like the
letter B and it's lowercase specifically
- it's a seventy million dollar sci-fi
film that robots name is Erica how much
of the robot cause 69 million I wonder
if you could just like in like how much
is 70 million worth of like LSD though
they could just pump into a theater in
every theater doctor kind of code just
like you watch like a regular like
cartoon nothing I'm damn sorry way
cheaper than that true I have an acid
since like I was forties a better
direction than robust wait a minute yeah
and you get woke up for that yeah have
you ever had nothing nice enough I've
never had asked that no I haven't had a
since I was 14 and antacid antacid I got
some Rolaids right here dude if you guys
want to go antacid we can go on a roll
yeah dude yeah so the movie is about I'm
trying to figure out what the movies
about
oh it follows a scientist who finds a
glitch in his DNA replication
replication research and helps
artificial organism pieces designed to
escape all one of my favorite grana is a
Honda hentai wait so is the character an
actual artificial robot yes well that
makes perfect she's playing herself
theoretically it makes entirely
course she's gonna beat us in the
rolling dislike being like on Jurassic
park's now using a robot dinosaurs
instead of real ones if she was like
playing like a regular human to be like
but I named it sanics then it'd be a lot
of actresses yes
hell yeah I would create another one and
call it Pinocchio and then so like the
mad scientist is like Geppetto I didn't
like what is it what you like it's
tighter oh that's so I'm hired you for
my creative my next question is like
what happens when she lies or what does
he get tighter and tighter to her
Geppetto yeah it doesn't seem like I'd
be lying all the time
yeah I'd say absolute I hmm I think that
it's actually real life we've yet to
disprove that mm-hmm
wait what's real life maybe baby girls
lie because she likes a [ __ ] tighter
not true she's a [ __ ] up again
that's why they keep saying your dick is
so big because it hides the [ __ ] that
[Laughter]
stuff [ __ ] Kegel tech me did and
we're really uncommon [ __ ] 2012 if we
all found no drown in a pool that we I
don't have swum guys I can swim very
well and I would never have a half above
half below ground pool we have a half
above ground jacuzzi in fact if you
don't know how to swim and you go to a
tropical vacation what's wrong with you
wait wet chart the beach yeah just a
minute dope in the water good yo fan
castles I usually call a knee deep in
the water well if you want to go [ __ ]
with sand you should go to the Sahara
Desert that's perfect if you don't know
how to swim I just imagine Joe as a poor
guy desert no I'm gonna bring me my my
tide and if I could when you start your
own tour guide somebody we just talk
[ __ ] to people all right I would you
came all the way to Hawaii and you don't
even like coconuts what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you don't eat raw fish I
don't know sir
I don't get that you came I don't know
unless you have a medical condition
people
should all swim in a tropical place it's
what's it's a waste it's like going to
China and not even like eating duck or
something it's like you gotta try like
you go to Amsterdam you don't get a
prostitute it's like going to the Alps
in that skin well I liked his Amsterdam
prostitute analogy yeah it's like but
there are other things to do in
Amsterdam there are way more no need you
smoke weed yeah
then prostitution the red-light district
nothing like a hundred people yeah
obviously something we're gonna say
prostitution but they're gonna for sure
be like weeds like legal if you had to
pick one in answer to him - do we - yeah
I went to him Sam I didn't get
prostitutes Joe what I yelled at you
smoked weed I did I got I was on a tour
and I got weed you stopped the guy was
like you know this is one of those cafes
wink wink me and my buddy went there got
hot ones a coffee shop he owns a cafe
yeah whatever one was given the weed so
we got we got pretty high hold then we
were on this tour again we went in this
church and was like one of these
churches that was like you know
historical for the Holocaust and then it
all hit us like a ton of bricks and
we're sitting there and I'm like oh [ __ ]
I don't like dude we got to get out of
here man I'm [ __ ] tripping like he's
like talking about the most serious [ __ ]
and I'm we're trying to keep it together
so we left the church
and we're sitting in this circle and
he's going on you're crying and then you
get a bar because you see a girl in the
window and it's all yeah it's all it's
all chaos man but then he's going on
about like the you know more like you
know serious like Holocaust stories and
I'm just high as [ __ ] and I'm like don't
look at Gyan don't look at the end don't
look at the end and I look over at
glance and he's like and I lost my [ __ ]
and I have like leave the tour
these are you crying I couldn't help it
man it was so bad I thought you were
actually gonna cry cause you felt bad
and you're just laughing just laughing
then I was like crying laughing that's a
problem that's true I can't even keep my
[ __ ] together at a drive-through if I'm
high I'm like I can't [ __ ] order food
to save my life
you start giggling yeah just like the
French toast sticks
and that becomes the funniest thing in
the world
Taco Bell they get it yes so many people
come if you go to talk about sober like
[ __ ] you doing here man yeah I've got to
talk about 2:00 a.m. and you're so
what's wood yeah sure yo taco bell's the
jam though doesn't matter they go no del
taco why are you dull tacos Alyssa's
right you guys ever have you had the
[ __ ] mild sauce though the mild sauce
would you go for the it's not cuz of the
spice cuz you know all those sauces
aren't spicy even talk about it's just
taste true the hot sauce is just
different tastes
I like the Diablo ones you know penis
you eat it
you don't even like their main [ __ ] you
like a sauce that already tells you a
pretty shitty have you tried to catch up
on McDonald's it's so good good that
makes sense though
it is no no no I am like going a
tropical vacation be like a donut shop
and ask for Apple nope yeah no but you
probably want a [ __ ] sample I don't
know the creamers that they use for the
coffee like have you tried to couriers
oh but a coffee shop is a donut shop is
coffee and donuts see so it makes sense
still it's not like you go to McDonald's
and you ask for a little ham you look
like the McRib yeah the big Ram why do I
remember the McRib is like having bones
into the whole thing is done the McRib
reminds me of elementary school rib
sandwiches yes I mean not real ribs is
just like I was jacked up - yeah I know
I just don't recall that yeah I didn't
have that
that's a vegan sandwich just tastes like
to me to have vegan burgers like they
taste like that that that that school
cafeteria be oh I miss the
foods dude from like third grading [ __ ]
I don't miss it the little chicken
sandwiches were good the little chicken
sandwiches were good and then we had a
salad bar so do please eat up for that
no I just there to get beat up there
yeah that's it no everyone did this we
got we'll get the salad and do it how
like unlimited corn and other things I
would drown it in dressing do that [ __ ]
was bomb just [ __ ] eggs out the salad
and keep the dressing yeah why don't you
just not do any of that in elementary
they didn't even have lettuce use that
corn cereal it's really good the best
part of my day corn in my ranch and
salad snip never gonna go in elementary
school you guys had a saddle okay
yeah it was a Ruby Tuesdays those are
Ruby Tuesday's a spice that's pretty
cool uh I know you guys weren't raised
here in LA but did you guys have the
taco boat which was a shell oh yeah Anna
Anna cheese with ground beef on top we
had that like special occasions we had
we had tacos in Jersey taco Paco's
injured we every time I talk about it at
school no boats at school yeah yeah yeah
it was like I don't it was like a half
shell I don't even know what it's called
you can't find it anywhere talk about
the hard shell hard shell taco right
talk about yeah it's like a little it's
like a bowl it looks like a bowl you
could buy the poles no it's not like
that
it's like a it's like a okay imagine
turtle shell right it's like that and
then all of it is just cheese and then
ground beef on like a chicken potpie
but for tacos and there's a shell on the
house they know I didn't have that yeah
I just had it tacos take away everything
I just said I think it was called the
chalupa to a made-up term all right
jimena is is a it's like a it's like a
half half rabbit half jackal that runs
around Texas and needs livestock
really really super Cabra but it sounds
like it sounds like it's totally made up
true which it couldn't be I'm a gordita
crunch y'all ready for this Santa
tan tan-tan tan tan-tan 10th okay [ __ ]
you you remember this [ __ ] right here
[ __ ] you don't remember this [ __ ] right
there oh yeah that's just a flat that's
flat top yeah yeah that's not a show
well I did this shell it's just thought
it was too lazy to form it I didn't have
that because basically like an unformed
talk it's a good bad what I never even
saw this I had him in a conclusion I
don't think robots are gonna take over
yeah true oh yeah oh yeah of what I
wanted to say earlier was since the
robot has no real life experience like
she couldn't actually pull from real
life to act they actually had to
manually plug in codes for her to
understand sadness and things like that
so which seems like a really uh it's a
slippery slope man you're specific yeah
I know yes different types of Direction
you're gonna learn how to [ __ ] yeah I
think it's just gonna be on our robots
to create art like having a robot become
a DJ or a robot becoming a musician
they're just not enough to pull from I
hope so I mean I hope yeah I hope so
it's eating our words and they're like
10 years and like a [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
fully alive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]